die junge generation muss auf die
politische agenda wir haben mittlerweile
als studenten vier semester hinter uns
was das bedeutet ist vor allem
planungsunsicherheit
wir wissen nicht ob wir in der nächsten
woche die vorlesungen und seminare
digital haben analog oder asynchron
was mit dem preis semester regelungen
vor allem im jura studium ist und wie
prüfungen stattfinden ob sie nachgeholt
werden können oder studenten auf das
kommende jahr vertröstet werden dazu
kommt und das ist ehrlich gesagt sehr
schlimm das thema einsamkeit unter
studenten wir haben mittlerweile lange
warteschlangen für psychosoziale
beratungen wir haben die situation dass
studenten wenn sie allein in ihren
ständen zimmern lernen zunehmend
vereinsamen nicht mit ihren kommilitonen
in die mensa gehen können oder zusammen
in der bibliothek lernen können im
gestrigen beschluss der
ministerpräsidentenkonferenz finden
wieder mal hochschulen und studenten
nicht den eingang in die
beschlussvorlage stattdessen werden klar
eröffnungs perspektiven für clubs
diskotheken großveranstaltungen
inklusive sportveranstaltungen klar
definiert wie da ein freedom day
aussehen kann deswegen fordere ich die
studenten und junge generation muss
endlich auf die politische agenda der
politik nach nunmehr zwei jahren und wir
brauchen einen wichtigen tag stichtag
für den freedom day für studenten und
junge leute frankreich gibt die
hundertprozentig recht ich glaube ihr
habt keine lobby weil er als
privilegiert geld das ist jetzt kein
scherz menschen haben das gefühl auch
wenn ich über die probleme in schwester
ist auch studentin
betriebswirtschaftslehre besteht ist
gerade ihren bachelor obwohl sie dieses
beschissene rom studium hatte er hat
sich großartig gemeistert aber ihr habt
keine lobby weil viele euch als
privilegiert empfinden und das ist
falsch weil viele sich das studium
finanzieren müssen sie müssen arbeiten
geht weiß was im schlimmsten finde ich
kriege andauernd moment leserbriefe von
studenten die gar nicht mehr studieren
dürfen wegen der einrichtungs bezogenen
impfpflicht und das finde ich fast noch
schlimmer neben eh schon den letzten
vier semestern die furchtbar für euch
alle warten ich hätte mein studium gar
nicht durchgezogen kann ich hier und
heute sagen ich brauchte die enge
betreuung mit pumpe ist so ich muss das
noch mal erklärt programm manchmal nah
an alexa und deswegen finde ich es ganz
schlimm es werden der lebensträume
genommen entweder durch die einrichtungs
bezogen pflicht oder weißen dennoch
einfach aufgeben ich hätte es auch nicht
in rom auf es geschafft niemals und
deswegen finde ich das unfassbar
wichtiger ist das thema mitgebracht und
das wesentliche in eine universität
einem universitäts lehrern ist ja der
untreue austausch also die betty die die
berühmtesten universitäten der welt oder
ist ein universitätsstädte heidelberg
tübingen nicht nur die aktuelle
absolut aber manchmal ärgert sich das ja
auch aber man sich man kann sich auch
wenn er geist verlieben sich verfahren
haben was mich am meisten wundert es ist
glaube ich nicht angekommen studenten
sind mittlerweile knapp drei millionen
in deutschland 82 millionen ist das
nicht mehr wie vielleicht vor 40 jahren
eine mini minderheit das ist eine status
gruppe die so nicht stattfindet ich habe
dazu nur zwei sachen beizutragen das
absurdeste was ich gelesen habt kommt
von der uni greifswald wo die
universitätsleitung den studenten
vollbärte untersagt hat die müssen sie
ab und da bin ich auch da damit die fdp
zwei maske passt und sich eng anliegt
das ist ja wirklich der hammer
schlechthin da weiter wo es ihnen
trotzdem das ist die wahrheit das ist
der wahrheit wirklich wie müssen sich
rasieren drucken dürfen sie stehen
lassen da passt die maske der un-mission
ganzen das kombi viren hervorgekrochen
ich bin ganz sicher
ganz einfach im internet zu finden
zweitens
die studierenden müssen sich wehren dass
wir müssen auf sich aufmerksam
wer einfach zu hause sitzen und vor sich
hin studiert der fällt nicht weiter auf
von den kultusministern ist nichts zu
erwarten auch von der
universitätsleitung nicht ihr müsst auf
der straße sein vielleicht solltet ihr
euch das ist ja jetzt sehr in mode sind
lokal ihr blut niveau fest leben also
100 mann in das arbeitsleben wurde der
einfahrt des kanzleramts fest leben wenn
herr mark owen zu besuch kommt so dass
der also dort 20 minuten warten muss bis
er wieder gelöst
es geht nicht
jetzt hat eine revolutionäre komponente
lernt also das werde ich eine kleine
bemerkung machen aber ich teile das aber
was mich noch viel mehr stört sind die
noch kleineren weil die haben noch
weniger einladen und die schülerinnen
und schüler die in den kitas na und die
dann betroffenen eltern die sind
wirklich die verlierer der pandemie die
studenten haben ja wirklich die chance
sich zu machen das ja auch
nicht so also allein schon wenn man die
berichte in zeitungen anschaut nein über
die kinder und das machen wir ja aber
ich finde es auch richtig
viel berichtet die studenten sind für
mich auch eigentlich auch große
vermieter eine punkt ist richtungen
schauen schauen sie mal langsam einander
aufwiegen werden nämlich gegen inter und
hielt nur ergänzen dass williams
beschluss von gestern steht drinnen jahr
die schüler und studenten wissen wir
also wir solidarisieren uns mit denen
sie haben also da probleme wir sehen die
einsamkeit etc mehr nicht was soll es
also was hat so
einen satz im beschluss von der mpk zu
suchen anstatt das mal zu diskutieren
breit und außen punkt 1.2 ist
könnte man nachvollziehen aber es ist
tatsächlich so dass man eben davon
ausgeht studenten sind erwachsene ist
ein junge erwachsene leute die können
sich organisieren die können
da quasi klare standpunkte setzen auf
wiegelt er und das ist eben glaube ich
das hauptproblem man gehe davon aus das
sind junge erwachsene die können das
schon selbständig machen wenn man aber
jetzt im zweiten oder dritten semester
studiert woher wissen sie wie ihre
kommilitonen sind woher wissen sie wie
ihr campus von innen ausschaut und das
ist wirklich der kernpunkt deswegen ich
auch heute hier bin um das thema
mitgebracht habe weil ich glaube aber er
ist es nicht gewohnt ruhigen vorbei ist
ja nicht auch wirklich so leider dass
viele der student oder wie man wie man
heute modernen sagen müsste studierenden
reicht
studenten strich studierende unterstrich
kern team trainieren denn dass die
meisten dieser diesen mentalitätswandel
diese obrigkeitshörigkeit für dich vor
angesprochen voll unterstützen ich und
sage ich ich ich bewege mich eine echte
lege mich ähnlich wie herr jörges nach
einer studentin
generation
die das was der staat vorschreibt
schrecklich findet ich wenn ich junge
leute sehe die finden das alle toll die
finden womöglich auch lauterbach toll wo
ist denn euer revolutionärer geist ging
wo ist denn der geist der rcds sagt ja
da ist verhält
nein also ist das englisch oder sogar
jürges mit dem ich wollte ich war im
jahr können wir ruhig vor dem kanzler an
clips lebe ich mich mit aber wie soll
ich die tür nicht nur omas gegen rechts
dann gibt es auch opas für studenten
die studenten an sich sehr solidarisch
verhalten ja die waren die gruppe die
auch wussten wir sind junge erwachsene
ich sage lieber nichts natürlich erst
die älteren und schwachen und auch
wichtig die schulen die kleinsten usw
nur und und das war bis zu einem
bestimmten zeitpunkt auch okay ja wo ich
auch sagt gut wir sind am anfang der
pandemien wir halten uns jetzt erstmal
solidarisch wir sehen jetzt ruhig schon
falsche wort aber gut nicht also das
quasi war nicht meine meinung also im
südlichen kann ja
und dann aber dass trotz dessen nach
eineinhalb jahren oder nach zwei jahren
jetzt nichts mehr passiert ist also
quasi wir so in vergessenheit geraten
sind und vielleicht auch noch nie auf
der agenda waren wahrscheinlich da mache
ich nicht mehr mit wie für mich
entscheidende frage ist wie reflektieren
sie denn als studierende das war es in
den letzten zwei jahren erlebt haben was
was schafft das für eine studentin
generation mit welchem bewusstsein kommt
die jetzt hier raus was lässt sie sich
nicht mehr gefallen was lässt sie sich
gefallen welche schlussfolgerungen zieht
sie aus dem allen wenn ihr euch
natürlich nicht unterhalten können weil
dadurch gar nicht seht ist das schon mal
schwierig aber sie jetzt als person
gefragt was ist ihre haltung nach zwei
jahren wir müssen uns da wir müssen uns
da vereinen und die politik auffordern
und das ist halt das nächste
hochschulpolitik ist immer ein anderes
thema also vor allem an die
landesregierungen herantreten unter
druck machen dass so ein flickenteppich
den wir während corona an den
hochschulen teilweise unterscheidet
sicher dass zu fachbereichen und
dozenten ob man digital oder im präsenz
meine erreichen anteil kaum jemand
seminar studiert hat das waren elf
studenten was ich hinterher weil die
noten dann mit matrikelnummer quasi
versendet wurden das war ein elf an der
zahl ich wusste nicht wer ein halbes
jahr den gleichen kurs mit mir hatte
konnte mich nicht austauschen nicht mal
über ich sag mal datenschutzkonforme
chat prozess gibt es alles das gibt es
auch unseres system her aber wenn der
professor das nicht anlegt weil ihm das
egal ist er sechs videos hochlädt ich
mir die videos alles stunden lang fragen
nicht beantwortet werden dann ist das
ein riesenproblem und dann deswegen mein
letzter punkt auf professoren dozenten
und die hochschulen sind in der
verantwortung nicht nur die politik aber
vor allem die da uns studenten
wahrzunehmen ich sehe sogar meine
schlussfolgerung der hat den erzählt er
sei ja früher
organisationen ist das jetzt anders
geworden das muss jetzt leider